élu policiers municipaux et bénévoles
ils sont une cinquantaine mobilisés sur
trois axes clés à poissy pour cette
quatrième journée sans poids lourds
seuls les véhicules en transit sont
concernés objectif lutter contre les
nuisances sonores les nuisances
olfactives et la pollution
typiquement ici nous sommes sur un
endroit où les poids lourds qui viennent
là viennent de saint germain et
maisons-laffitte
au lieu de continuer vers la rn 184 il
traverse la ville de poissy pour aller
chercher la 13 ce qui leur fait gagner
25 minutes et bien leur fait faire demi
tour
lors de la dernière opération 55% des
poids lourds contrôlés étaient en
infraction contre 70% entre la première
édition fois ci c'est très bien
moi j'habite aussi dans un des villages
qui peut traverser beaucoup camion mais
la camion s'est pas foulé
ville pas de verbalisation mais
seulement de la prévention et des
distributions de flyers pour cette
journée la municipalité souhaite
néanmoins aller plus loin moi je réclame
l'élargissement de la police du maire
pour justement faire en sorte que les
poids lourds qui traversent la ville de
poissy soit sévèrement verbaliser
aujourd'hui à la verbalisation à les
porter à 35 euros minorée à 22 euros
demain il faut porter ce chiffre à 500
voire 1500 euros une nouvelle opération
sans poids lourds à poissy devrait avoir
lieu au printemps 2020